au téléphone bas camara commente la
décision du tribunal de commerce de
versailles
ce représentant du personnel de
l'entreprise à ss sécurité implantée à
guyancourt vient d'apprendre la
liquidation judiciaire depuis quatre
mois date du départ du gérant de
l'entreprise pour le maroc
les 13 salariés ne perçoivent plus rien
tout le monde est actuellement sans
salaire sans travail jusqu'à la décision
finale d sera donné par le cabinet sam
zell et les juges
il a juste commissaire et
pour la reprise du personnel une
prochaine audience devrait avoir lieu le
18 octobre devant le juge commissaire
pour étudier les propositions de
plusieurs candidats repreneurs
un autre volet juridique est en cours
celui du 19 octobre les salariés
défendront cette fois leur dossier
devant le tribunal des prud'hommes
car autre complication dans le dossier
des salariés n'auraient pas été déclarés
ceux qui sont dans la légalité seront
bien garantie pour leurs arriérés de
salaire et leur solde de tout compte
assure de son côté le liquidateur
judiciaire
à plusieurs reprises nous avons tenté de
joindre la direction sans succès